hello you guys so today we're going to
do a Pacific uh wire gear uh 2021
programming
so it's a 2020 but the last month of the
year so I guess I think it's a 2021
bypass cable will be a very easy in this
case
we're going to have a cover right on
this panel you're just gonna take this
cover the star is right here
I'm putting the ADC 2011.
connected to an extension cord to the
OBD
okay and from that to the tool okay
now we're going to start doing the job
so it's going to be lost okay boss or
add a key situation
I like
when you come to the vehicle we're just
going to put the hazard lights on
and we're gonna go to Chrysler
we're just gonna go manual in this case
to make it easier
so we're going to treat it like an okay
last so let's say we don't have a key so
we're not going to put the key in the
ignition we're just going to press ok
so every time we're connecting with the
star or bypass it takes a little bit
longer
um to load this screen by the way if you
guys want to do it with the 12 8 you're
just gonna need to take this entire
thing out put your fingers really really
low over there and disconnect the 12 8.
the star is way easier using an
extension cord for the OBD
after we got to here we're just gonna go
control unit
and we're gonna go really mobilize our
password
and we're just gonna hit okay
um that thing will take like about three
minutes sometimes sometimes it's faster
my other tool can put uh can pull the
password faster than this but
you're just gonna wait make sure your
Internet is good
um in order to do that and
we will see when it's uh having the
password ready for us
so as you can see
uh we got the password
you could take a picture for that for
your own reference
and then we're gonna go to keyless
systems
um make sure if it's attic key just take
the working key outside the vehicle
so it's not going to bother uh the
signal
after we did that then we have only the
regular key that we want to learn with
us we're just going to go to key
learning
key learning
um it's going to tell us that there is
two keys and we want to learn the next
Key password is already there
I'm gonna press OK having the key on our
hands holding it about here
it just wants us to hold it next to the
push to start
so we're just gonna hold it around this
area
and then you're gonna need to press and
release
the unlock
and the job is done
we just press the unlock near that area
it's going to say current number of keys
three
and as you can see that key is already
operating we don't want to learn the
next key we're just going to hit no
this is how a job is done for uh
um 2021
Viagra
or Pacifica whatever you want to call it
thank you